welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with American
Horror Story 1984 opening a new chapter
in terror I thought I'd go back and look
at the real-life killers places and
crimes that inspired some of the show's
most sinister moments throughout this
video I'll be going over some of the
major things that led to the show's
scariest scenes there are some minor
spoilers here so if you aren't fully
up-to-date with everything before 1984
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without all the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for click in this
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the five real life killers places and
crimes that inspired American Horror
Story Briarcliff Manor in The Asylum
Briarcliff Manor is the central location
of season two of American Horror Story
titled the asylum this was pretty much
hell on earth throughout the show and
was the center of many ghastly
experiments human rights violations and
several murders whilst the manor seems
too evil to be an actual place the
inspiration behind it is in fact far
more terrifying Briarcliff Manor is
based on the real-life Asylum
Willowbrook state school this innocuous
sounding location was a
government-funded school that provided
support for children with learning
difficulties and disabilities the school
which was open from 1947 until 1987 was
initially supposed to only house 4,000
though these numbers increased to 6,000
over the years this led to a massive
outbreak of diseases including hepatitis
but rather than try and treat the
disease the children that lived there
were tested and experimented on to see
if there were ways to stop outbreaks one
of these experiments involved infecting
60 children with the disease and then
monitoring them this led to their eyes
and skin discoloring and turning yellow
and also caused mass vomiting all of the
children became ill and due to public
outcry the experiments were shut down
the psychopathic doctors that work there
try to justify the experiments by saying
that the children would all get the
disease anyway so it was okay to run
tests however after Senator Robert
Kennedy toured the building in 1965 he
said that the majority of those living
there were in unhappy tobol conditions
surrounded by dirt and in rooms that
were not even fit to be cages this led
to a huge decline in the reputation of
the school and its numbers slowly begun
to dwindle until 1986 when the
population sat in the 200s this led to
its closure though the pain caused will
likely live on forever in the victims of
the home the ghost nurses the ghost
nurses that are prevalent throughout
season one are actually based on
real-life murders that were carried out
by Richard Speck speck was a serial
killer who systematically tortured and
murdered eight student nurses from South
Chicago Community Hospital on July the
13th 1966 speck has re-emerged in pop
culture recently due to his appearance
in the Netflix series mind hunter in
which he leaves a chilling reminder for
the two protagonists that interview mass
murderers in the United States Ryan
Murphy co-creator of American Horror
Story stated that the nurses were
inspired by specks brutal killing spree
and that they Stan is a reminder of the
horrors that he inflicted and how his
murders ruin many lives the hotel Cortez
the hotel Cortez which appears in the
American Horror Story season Hotel 2 has
a dark inspiration behind it
the infamous Cecil Hotel the hotel
itself has been the home of over 30
deaths and acts of violence over the
years and it's gained a huge reputation
on the Internet
as one of the darkest places on earth
the 600 room Hotel has 19 floors each
one of them with a terrifying history in
addition to all the suicides Richard
Ramirez the serial killer known as the
Night Stalker was a regular guest there
and apparently engaged in some of his
killings whilst a resident at the hotel
Jack Unterberger Ostrom serial copycat
killer who was a fan of rummy
as to stayed at the hotel and similar to
the Nightstalker carried out multiple
murders whilst guests in 2013 the case
of ELISA Lam went viral due to CCTV
footage of her where she's seen acting
erratic at the hotel Lam looks like
she's hiding from someone and cowards in
a lift
before seemingly disappearing off screen
her body was later found in a water
cistern which residents had been
drinking from for weeks the entrance to
the cistern would have been far too
heavy for her to lift and due to her
behavior in the CCTV footage you get the
feeling that she was being followed as
of now though we don't know exactly what
happened to Lam and why she ended up in
the system and remains one of the
world's most famous unsolved mysteries
even with the rebrand as the stay on
main hotel it seems to be unable to
shake the bad luck surrounding it and
his notorious is one of the scariest
places on earth the hotel 2 shares some
similarities with HH Holmes infamous
murder castle which the notorious serial
killer had built in order to carry out
his killings easily which I'll discuss
in more detail in the next point James
March James March 2 appears in the
American Horror Story Hotel season and
the character played by Evan Peters is
inspired by HH Holmes who is thought of
by many to be America's first serial
killer Holmes was born in 1861 in New
Hampshire and moved to Chicago in 1886
where he slowly began to operate as a
hotelier after purchasing allot in 1887
on the grounds Holmes constructed what
will come to be known as his murder
castle the hotel was a maze full of
staircases that didn't go anywhere
hidden passages and rooms and hallways
that seemed to go on forever
Holmes soundproof rooms and built chutes
that led to a basement filled with a
crematorium and acid vats of the he
could dispose of bodies easily though
Holmes confessed to 27 murders upon his
capture the numbers are thought to be in
the 130 s and the fact that he was so
good at disposing of bodies allowed him
to operate for many years
Holmes left Chicago in 1894 and was
captured by police in 1895 where he was
subsequently hanged for his many crimes
Holmes is seen as America's answer to
Jack the Ripper though his killings go
far beyond the infamous Victorian
murderer
the vanishing Colony of Roanoke Roanoke
is one of the scariest seasons of
American Horror Story and it centers
around a ghostly group of settlers that
wish to bring terrible vengeance to
those that disturb their land The
Vanishing Colony of Roanoke
is regarded by many as America's oldest
unsolved mystery
up there with the Mary Celeste the
colony's disappearances went on to
influence the first settlers of Derry
and Stephen King's it though the true
story is even more terrifying the story
begins in 1587 and centers around a
group of English settlers that arrived
on Roanoke Island in North Carolina John
White the colony's leader decided that
he would sail the England for supplies
but after a war broke out between
England and Spain he was called up to
arms by the Queen White didn't get a
chance to return to Roanoke until 1590
which is when he returned to the
settlement to find that all had
completely disappeared his wife daughter
and granddaughter had completely
vanished and all that remained was the
word Croatoan carved into a wooden post
the word Croatoan has appeared at the
sites of numerous disappearances
throughout the centuries and it always
seems to be mysteriously linked to a
group of people vanishing Croatoan
itself was the name of a Native American
tribe from an island of the same name
and conspiracy theorists believe that
the group may have been abducted by this
tribe and cannibalized other people
theorized that they were absorbed into
the tribe and in 2007 there were
attempts to analyze the DNA of the
ancestors in the area to see if they
were part of the lineage though nothing
positive has come of this yet there's
also a possibility that the settlers
tried to sell for supplies themselves
after white did not return and they
either came face to face with the
Spanish army or met another fate at sea
either way their disappearance forced
the following settlers to be more
selective about where they decided to
place their
camps and this led the following
communities to thrive
Roanoke still stands is one of America's
biggest mysteries and it's unlikely that
we will ever get answers to exactly what
happened and that's our list of the five
real life killers places and crimes that
inspired American Horror Story obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
and which one of them you find the
creepiest comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of every time that
penny wise appeared in the background of
a scene in it chapter one and two I'll
go through both films and point out the
hidden appearances of the clown that you
might have missed so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this well ii just wanna let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of spider-man 4 from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
American Horror Story in 1984 in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]